[Painful scream]
KATE BISHOP
Who the hell was that?
FLORENCE PUGH
When there were early discussions of
if Yelena was gonna come back
I did not see it coming, that they were
gonna put me and Clint against each other,
which I thought was a really cool twist.
CLINT BARTON
Someone has hired a Black Widow assassin.
This has gotten very real, very quickly.
HAILEE STEINFELD
Yelena is such an amazing character,
and her and Kate have quite
a lot of fun together.
YELENA BELOVA
Kate Bishop.
[Groan]
YELENA BELOVA
Hi! I made macaroni, if you want some.
It's really tasty. Really tasty.
KATE BISHOP
I know what boxed mac and cheese
tastes like, okay? I know it's –
I know it's delicious.
RHYS THOMAS
Bringing someone like Florence,
it really brings in an interesting
dynamic with Kate.
Like, I think that's what was
really fun, was actually to see
how these two characters click.
BERTIE
To see Natasha Romanov's sister sitting,
talking to Clint Barton's protégé,
we just sat back and really enjoyed it.
YELENA BELOVA
I love American Christmases - the tree,
the super-powered reindeer!
Have you ever eaten reindeer?
KATE BISHOP
I cannot say I've had the pleasure.
YELENA BELOVA
No, it is not a pleasure.
It's really tough. It's chewy.
FLORENCE PUGH
When we finished Black Widow,
my whole experience was with Scarlett,
and she really welcomed me into the MCU.
And then to jump into her scene
partner's world was just as sweet.
It's been a really good
first two years in the MCU.